chantal ladesou un bon soir
chantal ladesou
vous avez un tel pouvoir comique que
pour être drôle rien qu'en disant
bonsoir à ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça le reiki et qui vous connais
bien m'a dit que vous étiez encore plus
drôle à poil c'est vrai et la pâte à sel
et circonvolutions incroyable en tous
les cas vous êtes la preuve vivante
qu'une femme peut être sexy avec la voix
de jean gabin c'était
alors on à faire le bilan
le bilan des gens qui ont marqué l'année
attention danger
[Musique]
alors d'abord un ya la pièce nelson un
triomphe ray
350 représentations ouais en fait vous
articulé tellement mal que les gens sont
obligés de revenir pour comprendre
il faut que ça marche
s'expliquant remplissage celle secret
les excès absolument leur nelson a c'est
le nom du lapin et pas du tout une pièce
sur mandela contrairement à ce que les
gens ont cru à l'essai a sûrement aidé
au remplissage les gens pensaient qu'ils
allaient une pièce intelligente sur
l'afrique du sud est sans appel et c'est
alors là la photo de nelson c'est la
dernière photo
oui on peut plus manger le lapin c'est
vrai que maintenant chaque fois vous
voyez un lapin combattu et où 17 à un
grand acteur qu'on est en train de faire
taire le c'est vrai vous êtes attaché à
la danse bah oui je suis un vrai plat
chez moi
je savais que j'étais pas l'abri d'avoir
le molière de la meilleure pièce avec un
lapin ouais
faits démentent
toujours dans le positif
toujours au théâtre au théâtre antoine
cette fois but sera la fiche de peau de
vache de barillet et grédy stains
classico chance d'animal
mais je suis une peau de vache quand
même encore un rôle quand même deux
femmes deux femmes autoritaires revêche
autoritaire mais c'est très amusant mais
sur quoi on a les rôles qu'on mérite non
c'est ce que mon mari me dit quand il
est énervé mais c'est vrai que un
personnage très autoritaire est très
très méchant qui va jusqu'au bout c'est
très payant bien sûr alors autre point
très positif du bilan le film que j'aie
sortir le 10 août c'est quoi cette
famille avec julie gayet julie depardieu
et claudia tagbo alors le pitch ça se
passe dans une famille recomposée
il ya un petit garçon qui a une idée
géniale y en a marre de sang à rédiger
de maison à maison de son père sa mère
ça et que d'autres copains ils
squattaient un appartement il ya sept
enfants qui sont un peu comme ça livrés
à eux mêmes toujours à le sac à dos on
va dormir chez un tel moment il faut
aller chercher le petit à l'école etc
donc il s'occupe de tout ils en ont
assez et ils ont décidé d'habiter
l'appartement leur grand-mère qui vibre
et qui est morte donc c'est un
appartement à ces grands ils vont
habiter là ils vont faire venir les
parents qui sait qu'ici se dispute qui
ce qu'ils s'entendent pas que toujours
des problèmes etc et du coup tout le
monde va se réunir là et ça va être la
fête et moi je fais une grand-mère quand
j' ai rien à [ __ ] de tout ça mais
aussi la complice de cette histoire -
dès le départ avant que les parents le
sachent je lui gagné le sympa charmant
ce qui montre son nom qu'il est cool
et la bollène fait chaud mais j'ai dit
non tu avais je laisse tomber leur temps
un copilote
ils sont frères
il s'occupe un peu de chantilly et oui
il est passé sur tournage elle n'est pas
passée sur le tournage or s'il est passé
sur tournage mais nous dire j'aime pas
d'accord regarde à quoi ça ressemble
je m'appelle bastien inamori c'est
sophie ma mère a eu trois maris mon père
c'est philippe le beau gosse populaire
après elle a épousé claude ils ont eu ma
soeur clara et puis alors en contre hugo
tu as he has been in tu frère gilbert
avant moi philippe a eu un oscar lac la
glène un rouge
léopoldine et juliette c'est mes
cousines défi d'agnès agnès c'est la
petite soeur de ben non elle a eu
leopoldina épaules et juliette il a
perdu son père
vienne qui paraît que ce baromètre
lavaud que quand il ya un coup à boire
et à manger et si loulou il a déjà un
premier fils de babel elliott la famille
nombreuse yparraguirre ex mais la
famille nombreuse recomposée ça c'est
nouveau et décontractée voilà ça sort
l'audition
alors il ya aussi quelque chose qui est
extrêmement positif
passé
et oui le grand mère cécile en rien
n'est bien me chantal
qu'est ce que ça fait je m'en rends pas
bien compte encore ah ouais ça fait peur
contre c'est à moi sans être à moi ouais
bon c'est déjà fait mais je suis ravi
c'est super le bébé s'appelle georges
oui vous prenez pour la reine
d'angleterre
bon maintenant le temps passer
chanter
il a menti négative la partie négative
et trouver quand même là j'ai trouvé un
truc les chercher bah ouais
ben othman a déclaré un jour vous vous
réveillez vous avez un vieux dans votre
lit le problème c'est que vous avez le
même âge que lui
on a fêté nos 41 ans de mariage d'accord
mais vous n'êtes pas au théâtre on
commence à s'engager ce que je vais vous
dire bah ouais bah oui mais c'est en
même temps le secret le secret de la la
fidélité de secrète tout ce à quoi le
secret secret sept singles et envoyer
chier et mes deux s'entendent très bien
d'être complice quand même c'est à dire
qu'on s'engueule ica que la porte il
s'en va deux minutes après le téléphone
on a tout oublié mais ça c'est alzheimer
[Applaudissements]
alors votre mari on a dit qu'il a failli
se barrer avec le lapin pour devenir son
manager
même et oui non mais c'est vrai le lapin
il dit rien il ferme sa gueule tu dit
pas la vérité passe quand tu fais des
one woman show ton mari vient avec toi
toujours que ce sont aux mains de dieu
guérit tous les soirs un thierry tous
les sens même la régie ça veut dire mais
c'est incroyable il l'a déjà vu depuis
eri c'est ça le secret vous subjuguer
comble c'est vrai
g
adam chantal vous êtes une reine du
boulevard vous ne serez pas étonné que
tu fasses une interview au théâtre ce
soir
[Musique]
je vais vous donner des petites de
pièces de théâtre voilà vous allez me
dire si ça a existé ou pas
boing boing boing boing 1960 marc
camoletti y aurait 20 ans 30 ans
jouera toujours rafael rafale n'ont qu'à
se cache
6,71 albert rousseau oui
pouet pouet oui non à van persie du rhum
du rhône non c'est un groupe musical hu
a reconnu simon des relations assez fort
à miami non
6,67 jean pierre darasse tac tac non toc
toc
[Musique]
zigzag non non fric frac oui à bravo
1936 edouard bordé oui métier déjà la
chine chiens non si avant 2012 fabrice
roger lacan j'étais pas là
big bang oui oui 2012 entre le rich gang
bang
c'est un privé
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous mais
facebook